en france et c'est une spécificité
française est là ça nous ramène
peut-être bien aux sujets d'origine
c'est qu'il y a non seulement une
défiance du peuple vis-à-vis des élites
mais il ya aussi une très grande
défiance des élites vis-à-vis du peuple
et ça c'est lié à notre histoire et
notamment à la révolution française
c'est beaucoup plus marquée que dans
d'autres pays et il ya des éléments très
très notable qui structurent toute notre
histoire depuis deux siècles et qui nous
permet de comprendre les équipes
françaises ont cette singularité elles
ont beaucoup plus peur du peuple que
d'autres élites italienne allemande par
exemple ou d'autres
c'est paradoxal mais en règle ça depuis
dix depuis la révolution depuis on peut
dire quasiment le massacre du champ de
mars
les les élites révolutionnaires qui ont
commencé la révolution ont commencé la
révolution avec le peuple et se sont
rendus compte que finalement le peuple
il était dangereux parce qu'il pouvait
toujours aller un peu plus loin j'ai un
autre élément qui nous revient à
l'esprit par exemple on sait que la
propagande au moment de la première
guerre mondiale
la propagande était beaucoup plus forte
en france que dans le reich allemand ou
que dans les empires britannique par
exemple
oui c'est ses traits marquants il ya une
sorte de crainte française vis-à-vis de
l'élite et ça se renforce et ça sera
peut-être l'objet de notre la suite de
notre discussion ça se renforce depuis
1945 par l'existence d'un autre soit
constitué un entre soi élite est
reconstituée avec notamment des
formations comme l'ena ou polytechnique
mais enfin surtout les nains qui permet
au fond à un tout petit groupe de très
bien se connaître c'est lié aussi au
fait de notre histoire de la
centralisation d'autres pays comme je
parlais de l'allemagne ou de l'italie
étant des pays décentralisé il ya il ya
des élites beaucoup plus diffuse que en
france un anglais et je finis disait
vous cette blague ci ont lancé une bombe
sur le 6e et le 7e arrondissement il n'y
a plus rien en france et toutes les
élites ont disparu donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très spécifiquement
français
[Musique]